apparently there's a conspiracy theory
going around that our cabins are all
green screen are y'all okay I guess it
doesn't matter that there's tons of
videos of us building these things
including two YouTube series so come on
let's go I'll prove you wrong first of
all if this were green screen why would
I show you right now are roof all brown
and dry and icky instead of just
gorgeous and beautiful and green like
this all the time I wouldn't okay now
let's go over to the Wardrobe cabin I
mean if this were green screen would I
be able to walk over here and peel the
roof up like this no probably not okay
on to the diamond cabin I really didn't
want to have to do this but I am willing
to go to any length to prove my point
okay see I even saw one person say isn't
it suspicious that you never hear birds
in the background of their videos well I
don't really know Jerry maybe because of
global warming and all the animals are
dying or is that idea just too far for
you all right it's real it's here now
Shish